This is a PSA. If you're a woman in Australia or an ally
who cares about how many women this year have been killed
and the ongoing scourge of violence against women in this country.
There are rallies in almost every city and many,
many regional centres. Please come.
There are amazing speakers.
I know that because I am one of them.
I am going to be speaking in two of the regional centres
because a lot of violence against women is regional
and we often get forgotten about.
I will be speaking tonight at the Ballarat rally at five PM
and I'll be speaking at the Bendigo rally at 11:00am on Sunday.
We are saying no to violence and we are demanding preventative,
proactive action from our government on this epidemic.
One woman every four days has been killed
on average here in Australia this year.
This year, 31 women this year.
Today, the Harvey Weinstein case got overturned.
If that doesn't make you mad,
wanting to rally, I don't know what will.
Our stories and our voices have remained invisible,
unheard, unseen for far too long
and they are no longer invisible.
We together can make sure our stories are heard.
We are more powerful when we stand together as a collective.
These events are about demanding change,
but they're also about hope and justice and collective action.
I really hope that I see you there.